例えばこのジャヴァーナ・ニエマということを一応やってましたし
ジャヴァーナっていうのは即行心
ニエマっていうのはどのようにこの即行心が生まれますかという法則なんですね
で 一般的な世俗的な いわゆる欲界心の普通の心の場合は
即行心は必ずしも七つぐらい生まれるという風に
アビダンマでは決まってるんです
それで禅定とかね 心を育てて
サマーディ そういうものなど作る場合は七つには限らないんだと
で 変わるんだということで
そちらへはちょっと法則が変わるんです
で もう一度言うあれば
普通の人々は見たり考えたり
感じたり味わったりするときは
即行心はだいたい七つ生まれるんです
それで普通の心ではなくて
まあ瞑想してサマーディ状態まで心を大心のレベルに次元を乗り越えると
普通の欲界心のレベルから心を大心というレベルまで
まあ登るというか まあ上がってみると
その時も その時も必ずしも即行心七つ生まれるということではないんだそうです
その説明なんです 今日はもしかするとこのページのを四番目からだと思います
こちらで言っているのは
このアーディ・カンミカッサ
初めて禅定を作る人にとっては
あのアンシ 即行心というか
このジャーナの心 サマーディの心が一つしか生まれませんと
だから一つの親切なチッタックスな一つだけだそうです
で サマーディ生まれる前に
その最後の心のセットで
まあパリカンマ・ウパチャーラ・ゴートラブーという心が三つ順番で生まれるんですね
パリカンマ・ウパチャーラ・ゴートラブー
それからサマーディの心
で パリカンマ 説明しましたから
また説明しちゃうと時間なくなりますからね
パリカンマっていうのは
このサマーディの心が作られる準備のような心で
ウパチャーラっていうのはサマーディにちょっと
ちょっと似てきたような心で
で ゴートラブーっていうのはもうほとんどサマーディ状態に似た状態で
それでも欲界心なんですね
その時はこの欲界心の専心
まあこちらでは書いてないんだけど
私はだいたいこの智恵僧を専心するの一つかで即行心していると思います
で ゴートラブーというところで
もうゴートラブー心は欲界心なんですけど
心としてはサマーディの心にものすごく似ているんですね
街に立てれば あるいは何かこの劇場なんかに立てれば
もう劇場のもう入り口に入って
もうチケットも渡したぐらいの状態なんですね
もうチケットも渡しちゃったら
もう中に入ることは当たり前で
すぐ中に入られるから
それぐらい自分の心がこのサマーディ状態にもう
もう全く似ている状態になってくる
その心はゴートラブーと呼ぶんです
で ゴートラブーという言葉を使っているのは
この次元を破るという意味なんですね
次の心は全く次元違う心が生まれるんだと
その心に普通はアンシですか
アッパナという一般的な名前を使ってますけど
まあジャーナ・チッタですね
禅定の心なんです ですから即行心というのはだいたいパリカンマ・ウパチャーラ・ゴートラブー・ジャーナと四つですね
生まれるのは 七つ生まれません
それは初めての禅定を作る時
それから下生縁生まれて
心が下生縁生まれてか生まれないかということはまた別な話で
えーとまあ心が不分心に戻っちゃうんです
そこでこの初めて禅定に入るということは
例えば普通の人は瞑想したら
一番初めに入るのは第一禅定
その自分の人生の初めての場合は
このジャーナ・マッグチッ・ジャーナチット
安心ですか それは一回しか生まれません
ほんの瞬間だけ で 第一禅定に入った
得た人がさらに瞑想すると
第二禅定に入ることはできるんです
その場合も初めてだから一回なんですね
いつでもこの安心場の心の前にある心にゴートラグーと言うんです
この次元を破る前の心にゴートラグーというようになっているんです
それで次のポイントはこのローコーットラチッタなんですね
出世間心なんですね で
瞑想ではなくて ヴィパッサナーにおいて
あの 仏教で言ってる悟りの境地を体験することはできるんですね
で サマーディと似ていますけど
ちょっと働きが違うんですね
で ものすごくあの禅定の心所よりは智慧の心所を活動させちゃうんですね
禅定というのは気持ちよくなるし
統一するし 一つになる感覚なんですね
で 一つになればなるほどボケちゃうんです
何 何やってるかと なんか分からなく状態になるんです
ですから この智慧がなかなか機能しなくなるんで
でも禅定を作るためには智慧が確実に必要なんです
智慧なしに禅定できるということはありえないんですが
智慧といったってはいろいろ働きあるんだから
普通に我々何かもう大事な品物を壊れた
その瞬間で驚かないで
あぁやっぱりまあ壊れるもんだと思ったならば
心その瞬間で落ち着いてるんですね
あ なんてことするんですかと
あ 大変だと思ったら 欲界の人で
その時じゃなくて まあやっぱりまあ壊れるもんやと思った瞬間でも無常を見てるんですね
当たり前だと 壊れるのは
いくら大事なものであろうと
それも智慧なんですね
ですから 智慧があると心は落ち着いているんです
だから 人が悟っても悟らなくても
仏教であろうとなかろうが
それに関係なく 智慧っていうのは
まあその人その人生まれる時はあるんです
自分の まあ大体智慧があると悲しみ苦しみがないんです
例えば自分の一番大事な人が急に末期癌だと言われたら
智慧がない場合はものすごく落ち込んでしまう
ショックを受けちゃう
意識がなくなってしまう
その時は智慧がないんですね
欲の世界で働いてます
それに怒ってるんです
見たくないもの 聞きたくないもの
聞きたくないんだと 求めたく
認めたくないんだというのが怒りなんです
怒りによって人は失神になったりもします
ものすごいショックを受けちゃう
落ち込む 例えば自分もすごく大事な人かもしれませんだけど
末期がんですよと言われたら
ああそうですかね やっぱりと
世の中ではそれはあり得るものだ
そう思ったならば その瞬間であのショックも何もないんですね
何もなく なんかすごい落ち着いていられるんですね
ですから この智慧は苦しみを消してくれるんです
そこで ああ やっぱりそうでしたかと思った瞬間で
じゃあ次に じゃあそれからどうすればいいかということに頭が行っちゃうんですよ
ですから 智慧っていうのは素晴らしいことなんです
人が死んじゃった あるいは麻痺になったという報告したところで
まあここは失神になっちゃって
もう倒れたとかね こちらも心身発作を起こしちゃって病院に運ぶようになったと言っても
何の意味もないんですね
結局 一つの損の上でもう一つ損が起きただけのことなんですね
落ち込んで一生苦しんでいたんだと
旦那さんが死んだところから死んで
また十年経ってまだ奥さんが悩んでるとか
そういうのはいくらでも世の中にあるケースですからね
そういうのは無知の人々の世界の生き方で
それによって苦しみが生まれる
ですから まあ人が死んだと聞いても
病気だと聞いても ああそうかという感じで
別にありえないことがあったわけじゃないし
全てはそういう運命になっているんだというふうな感じで見ると
落ち着きがあって それから
じゃあこれからどうすれば
どんな態度を取ればいいかというひらめきも
するすると頭の中にすぐ浮かんでくるんですね
そういうことで 仏教では徹底的に人に感情の代わりに智慧のことを推薦しているんです
ですから 私は今言いたがっているのは
智慧っていうのは普通の世界の中でも
人間にはまあその都度その都度現れるものなんです
その瞬間で その人はやっぱり落ち着きを感じる
苦しみを感じないんです
で 驚きも感じないんです
まあ私は聞いた話なんで
例えばすごいもう大金の宝くじ当たったと聞いたら
その当選番号見たところで
またあまり驚いて死んじゃったとか
ですから 幸福な時でも
やっぱり無知な人は不幸になっちゃうんですね
その時も智慧のある人は
ああそうかと という感じで
それからどうすればいいかということを
次に頭に流れていくんですね
ひらめきが ですから 常に人間に必要なのは智慧でありますし
それは何とかして育てようと
だから 散々この無常のこというのは
悟らない人であろうが
修行しない人であろうが
もう徹底的に頭に叩き込めば
この無常の感覚概念を無常に基づいて物事を考えるようになってしまえば
それは智慧の人間の生き方なんですね
その人は誰よりも幸福に生きていられるし
誰よりもその人に物事についてひらめきがあって
判断能力があるんですね
悟らなくてもそれぐらいのことはできるんです
ですから まあそれは覚えてほしいところ
それから禅定なんか作る時でも
智慧というものは必要なんです
その場合はどういう智慧が必要かというと
人間にとって幸福っていうのは
ものを見て味わって 食べて
寝て みんなと世間話を喋って
友達を作って そういうことは本当は幸福ではないんだと
そんなことは何の意味もないんだと
眼耳鼻舌体に耐えたら苦しみしか得られないと
眼耳鼻舌身から離れて心を通じすればどうですかという判断能力あった人にだけ禅定が生まれるんです
瞑想したんだからといって禅定は生まれません
瞑想において この眼耳鼻舌身に耐える自分ことはバカバカらしいんだと
無意味だと自分で納得していかなくちゃいけないんです
なぜ人がいくら瞑想したっても禅定ぐらいでも生まれないかというと
心で納得していないんですね
この見るものは楽しいというふうな納得があるんだけど
見るものは面白くないと
聞くものも面白くないと
煩わしいんだと 味にこだわることも
体の感触にこだわることも
頭の概念にこだわることも
煩わしいんだと そういうことから離れた方が大変落ち着いて幸福だという納得がないんですね
ただ言われるんだからやると
やっぱり瞑想ぐらいもしなくちゃいけないんだからと行って
この義務感覚でやるとかね
そういう風にやっちゃうと
禅定のような次元破ることは不可能なんです
瞑想はやるかもしれませんだけど
次元は破ることはもう不可能なんですね
ですから 禅定を作るためにも智慧というものは必要なんです
そこで出世間心の場合は
もう純粋に智慧の働きになっちゃうんです
で 智慧っていうのは ですから
いろんなもん いろんなレベルがあるんです
一般的な人々の中でも智慧が現れたりするし
瞑想する人々の中にもその都度その都度智慧が現れたりするし
ヴィパッサナー瞑想する人にとっても
その都度智慧が現れることがあるんです
それはまあ刃物と同じもんなんで
刃物っていろいろ種類があるんだからね
その種類によって切れるものは違うでしょう
ノコギリだったら切れるものと
ペンナイフだったら切れるものと
文化包丁で切られるものとか
それまたまた決まってるんですね
刀で切られるものとかね
ですから あの刃物には変わりはないんだけど
カミソリも刃物なんですけど
でもそれに切られるものは違うんで
ですから それ全部まとめて刃物という
そういうふうに我々は
この無知を切るものは智慧というんです
人間の苦しみを切るものには智慧と呼ぶんですが
何を切るかということによって智慧のランクが決まってしまうんですね
そこでサマーディ作る人はやっぱり智慧があるんだけど
まあ眼耳鼻舌身に頼らずに何か他の何か対象がないかということで瞑想するんです
仏教ではそれを明確にしているんですね
サマーディを作りたい人が何か対象を作りなさいと
何か瞑想する対象を作って
それを見て瞑想しなさいと
そうするとすごい明確なんです
何か対象に頼っているということ
で 仏教以外の宗教の瞑想でもきちんと対象があるんで
神様とかね 神様に念じる場合は
自分信仰している神様を対象にして瞑想する
あるいは何かマントラとかね
音を あの基本的エネルギーはヒンドゥー教だったら
対象というよりは何か基本的なエネルギーをとって瞑想するとこもあったんだから
マントラとかマントラっていうのは音なんですね
そこを唱えることによって音に集中する
それで何か禅定が生まれると
そこに何か対象が確実にあるんですね
ですからそこでサマーディ状態が生まれる
で いわゆるサマーディっていうのは
この何ですか 一体感みたいなものですね
その対象と自分が一つになる
自分が消える サマーディ瞬間で自分という概念消えちゃうんです
消えて この一体になってしまう
自分今まで見ていた瞑想対象が自分を襲ってきて
自分を抑えて自分を乗り移ってしまっちゃう
そのものすごい瞬間の出来事なんです
次の瞬間でまたうぶんしになりますけど
その瞬間にサマーディと呼ぶんです
でも人はそういう経験というのは全然味わえない
我々はいつでも自分が別にいて
世の中を見ているという感じがあるんですね
いつでもですから この自分という実感があるんです
もし自分を忘れてものを何か見たりとかね
映画でも本でも音楽でも聴いてる途中で
なんか我が身は忘れた瞬間で喜びが多いんです
それは即次元なんですけど
あの まあ何て言いますか
欲 欲 快の次元ですけど
ですから 本当は人間には自我忘れた瞬間こそが喜びを
救国的に強烈に感じられる
ですから大体音楽を聴いて自分を忘れる人がいるし
踊りながら自分を忘れる人がいるし
ある宗教グループいるんですね
日本におりますけど なんでハレラーマハレクリシュナのグループが
だから歌っては踊る 宗教はそれだけ
歌もたった一つしかない
ハレラーマハレクリシュナ
それだけ歌う それはやっぱり一つのヒンドゥー世界の一つの修行方法なんですね
それを何か現代人に気に入られて
で みんなまあ菜食主義になって
白い服を着て頭を剃って
朝から晩まであの曲だけを歌う
そうするともういるんです
そういう人々が なんかぼけーっとして自分を忘れてしまって
自分が何やってるかわからない
ただ歌ってるだけで 自我意識が消えるんだ
それは彼らにとっては梵が一に
梵天と一緒になったという風に解釈するわけです
それが目的 それで終わり
その宗教は ですから狂ったような感じで歌えと
で まあそれもそれなりに人々が作ったメロディーだから
たった一行だけ歌ってるんだけど
何回聴いたって別に気持ち悪くはなることはないんです
ですから そういう風に長い間で出来上がった曲だから
別に気持ち悪くなる曲ではないんだけど
聞いたら誰でもあれ気に入られるようなメロディなんですね
で それでみんな必死になって歌ってもらう
そういう風にこのサマーディっていうのは
この俗世間で起きたっても気持ちいいものなんです
いわゆる自分がいるという
別々に自分がいるんだという
この区別感が消える瞬間
そういうような感覚ですか
大体世の中で人々にたまにでもあることなんですね
面白い すごい面白い本を読んだ時とかね
すごい面白い音楽を聴いた瞬間とかね
ずっとないんだけど ある瞬間でもう自分を忘れてそのものと一緒になるということはあり得るんですね
サマーディの場合はもっとすごい
このレベルがものすごい強烈で
ずっと一応一体感があるんです
サマーディ瞑想すると
例えば何か対象を取って瞑想しますね
対象を見て瞑想してから目を閉じてみる
目を閉じてみたら 自分にそれでその対象を見られる
で この前質問がありましたけど
例えば我々にイメージをとって頭でイメージを作ることはできますけど
それはもう認めないんです
イメージではなくて ちゃんと見たものを目を閉じても頭の中にそんなままある
ですからイメージとは違うんです
イメージっていうのは画家の世界でよくあるものなんですね
本当にプロの画家になったら
もう描く前に頭にこの映像がもう全部できたものが浮かんであるんですね
描く前にも最後の最後の出来た映像がそこにあるんです
それはもう自分が筆を持って表現すると
そういうのはイメージであって
この場合はこの現実にすごい明確に本人に見える
そう見える状態になったところから
もうその人はすごい喜びを感じ始めるんです
それからさらに瞑想すると
その対象がどんどん明確になってきて
光になってきて 確実に光になるということはないんだけど
とにかくこの パティバーガニミッタという専門用語がありますけど
このニミッタですか その相がこの生まれてくるんですね
そのパティバーガニミッタっていうのは
この対象は完璧に見られる瞬間
作る人間 作る対象には欠陥があるんです
青い色の円を描いて瞑想しようと思ったっても
完璧な青い色の円を描くことはできないんです
作るものだから それから頭の中でそれを映してもらって
それから瞑想すると完璧な形にそれ見え始めちゃうんです
それはパティバーガニミッタで
それからさらにそれは光に変わっちゃうんです
変わった瞬間で瞬間かどうかわかりませんだけど
さらに瞑想を続けると
その対象が自分を襲うんですね
襲って自分を忘れて その対象と自分も一つになってしまう
ということは後でわかるんであって
その瞬間でそれさえわからないんです
何が起きたかと 自分知ってるのは対象あったんだけど
自分が消えたということだけ
それはサマーディが生まれたということなんです
で そこでそういうのは一般的な心の働き
それには宗教は関係ないんです
そういう経験というのは
誰にでも体験することはできるんです
そこで問題は そういう大胆な体験を得た人は
そのところから絶対離れないんです
これこそ正しいんだと
これこそすごいんだと
それにすごく徹底的に執着するんです
で 例えばハレー ラマ ハレー
クリシュナという歌を歌って
頭でああいう風な一体感を得た人がいたならば
やってみてください 他の宗教の概念なんか教えてあげようと
世界中人類みんなまとめてあなたおかしいですよと言ったって聞いてくれないんです
あなた方がおかしいんだと
私は経験しているんだからと言うんです
そういうなんとなく経験させることはキリスト教にもあるんです
この洗礼儀式っていうのは
そういうことのためにあるものなんです
すごい大祭りをして ものすごい尊い感覚をまず最初から作ってあげて
で これからもう神の子にしてあげると
これから何でしたっけ？ホーリーゴーストって何でしたっけ？聖霊をあなたの心に宿るんだとということで
水の中に入れちゃうんですね
それは冬に入れた方が一番いいと思いますけどね
で あの まあ水かける場合は
赤ちゃんなんかには水ちょっとかけるだけなんですけどね
赤ちゃんはもう中に入れた方がいいと思います
中に完全に入れるんです
それは宗派によって仕来り変わりますけどね
ジェイソン様も完全に水の中に入り込んで洗礼を受けたんだからね
なんでジェイソンそれやるんですか？やっぱりわからないんですね
まあ解釈してるのは自分も他の人々と同じですよと認めなさいと
ということでね 私はまあ神ですが
もうジェイソンに洗礼したの誰でしたっけ？あのジュアンじゃない
え ジュアンですね まあでもやってくださいと頼んでやってもらったんですけどね
で その時もやっぱり経験する人々いるんです
なんか自分の心に入りましたと
で それそういう経験があったら
その人はもう徹底的にその信仰にしがみついて生きているんですね
だからそういう風に その
その各宗教がもう狙っているというかね
人の心を掴むこと で 強力
強力なんです もう一旦そういう経験を得たら
もうその人にはもう救い道が人間よ
もんだからね もうないんです
一般的に言えば で そこで仏教はそういう経験は否定してないんです
なぜならば 心はそういうふうな成長の過程だから
これはもう宗教と関係なく
心の普遍的な法則なんです
ですから 禅定を得た人に
仏教では特別にさらに訓練させちゃうんですね
その特別な訓練はこのパンチェ・ワシという
パンチェというのは五つ
ワシっていうのは自由自在になるということですね
ですから まあご自在ですね
で 五つの立場で この禅定について自在になる
自由になる いわゆる自由に操れるようにすると
そうすると瞑想に襲われる
抑えられることはなくなっちゃうんです
禅定を自分で管理するようにできるんです
そこで一番目はこのアワッジャナ・ワシというんです
この頃頭ボケてますから忘れる可能性ありますけど
アワッジャナ・ワシ アワッジャナっていうのはあのテキストにありますか？どこかに
285ですかね  一応その言葉
うん で 一番目は因典自在かもしれません
いわゆるこの英語ではリフレクションなんですね
で 一番目 この自分が禅定に入って
次に有分身になる 有分身になったら普通の欲界の心に戻っちゃうんですね
戻ったら自分に何が起きたかと
また一旦過去の瞬間に戻って思い出して
そういうどういう状態だ
この禅定って 禅定とはその時わかりませんだけど
自分に起きた状態はどういう状態かと観察してみるんです
そうすると迷うことはないんです
これこそ梵我一如だ これこそ神と一体化だと
これこそゼーレだととかなんとかとか
この解釈はしない だから解釈は絶対してはいけないんです
解釈すると間違うんです
でお釈迦様 すごくお経
お経の中で なんであらゆる宗教家が解脱見つからなかったか
なぜみんな訓練の途中で止め
やめ 止め やめて止めたんですかと
解釈なんです 本当は高度な体験持ってるんです
特に現代宗教家っていうか
お釈迦様 あの比べて あの批判している宗教というのは
みんなもう超自然的なもう能力持っていた人々なんです
いわゆる瞑想して そういう禅定体験あった人々なんです
ただの宗教家じゃないんです
だから そういう人々の世界では
なんで解脱まで至らなかったかと
その人々は解釈するんです
説明するんですね 自分の状態を
それで間違うんだと 説明すると固定概念で
今まで自分が持っている概念で説明しなくちゃいけない
初めて得た経験は固定概念で説明するのは不可能ですという立場なんです
お釈迦様は で 残念ながら人間いつでもそれやっちゃうんですね
初めて外国に行った時も
時そのまま見ないで日本のものと比べる
あ これは日本のなんとかと違います
あ これは日本のなんとかと似ているんだとかね
そういう癖っていうのは人間にあるんです
ですから 禅定を得た人が
今まで自分が勉強した文化背景から解釈する
解釈すると間違うと ですから
絶対解釈だけはやめて
そのものを見るだけにしなさいと
というのは お釈迦様の瞑想の指導の立場なんです
ですから 解釈することをやめるために禅定を得た瞬間で
次に心が普通に自分の意識に戻るんだから
何が起きたかと その禅定について明確に観察する
リフレクションする それはですから
因転自在とこの漢字あててるんですけどね
2番目何でしたっけ これですね
うんと もうすぐわかるじゃないかな
思った通り サマーパッジャナーヴァシー
2番目はサマーパッジャナーヴァシーというんです
日本語で入定自在なんですね
定というのはサマーディ
で 自分が一回禅定作ったら
それでよしと言って満足しないで
何回何回ももう何百回でもいいんだけど
またまた瞑想して またまた瞑想して
同じ禅定に入ってみる
いわゆる自由自在に自分を得た
この超自然的な体験に入ることを訓練するんです
一回だけでは良くないんだと
だから何回何回も入ると
これどういう経験かと自分でどんどん分かってくるんですね
一回だけだったら安心は一筋しか生まれません
そんなわずかな経験について膨大な解釈しちゃうと
もう明確に間違ってるんです
ですから 何回何回もこの禅定に入りなさい
すぐ入れるようにしなさい
訓練する 次はウッダナーヴァシーでしょうと思いますけどね
でしたっけ あ アディッタン
アディッタンナヴァシーサンバンネ
このアディッターナという言葉はちょっとまあ疑問なんですけど
アディッターナの普通のパーリ語の意味っていうのは誓願なんですね
決まることなんですけど
その意味で使っているわけじゃないんです
ですから 違う言葉で私は覚えたんだけどね
日本語で何でしたっけ
最常慈済という最といういるサマーディにいること
いわゆる これは本当はサマーパッティワシと言った方が分かりやすいと思いますけど
サマーパッジャナワシなんですけどね
それサマーパッジャナですからね
ですからサマーパッジャナワシ
サマーパッティワシというふうな言葉に入れた方
言葉にした方が 私としては意味が理解しやすいんですけど
で なんでアディが入ったかということも
ターナはいいんですけどね
それはまあ決まってる言葉だからしょうがないんだけど
意味は最常慈済 禅定に入って
この瞬間でそれで終わらないで
長い間いられるように
もう訓練する で 本当のサマーディ
最初に生まれる時は一つの新雪な
それはできればこの経典でこれこれではなくて
注釈書で書いているのは
この指をこうやって鳴らすぐらいの時間でもいられるようにしなさいと
その時はたくさん生性が生まれて死んじゃうんです
それくらい時間でもそのサマーディに入っている状態作れと
それからそれをもうちょっと伸ばしてみると
そういう風にサマーディの状態で時間伸ばしていられる訓練する
4番目はもしかするとウッターナでしょう
4番目ウッターナ・ヴァシー
かな なんかちょっと ウッターナでもいいしウッタナーナでもいいんです
ただ抜けちゃって言うだけでもいいんです
パーリ語から考えると
ウッターナっていうのはこの出場
出場慈済 いわゆるサマーディから出るという意味なんですね
出場慈済 で そういうサマーディみたいな
この大胆な経験を得たら
なんかそれでなんかすごいショック受けちゃって
もう長い間何が何だか分からなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから それを消すためにこの出場慈済を訓練するんです
で そこは一般的な考え方なんですけど
瞑想しちゃうと頭が狂っちゃうよという話が一般的にあるんです
そういう人々もいるんです
それはもうやり方がもう間違うと起こり得ることなんです
別に狂ったかどうか また別の話で
一般の人から見れば あの人おかしいんだと
だと言われるんです もしなんかそういう想像を接する経験があった人が
それから世の中のことを全部忘れて
そればっかり考えて生きていようとするんですね
たまに一般の世間の中でも
誰かになんかもうある日突然禅定状態が生まれて生まれ生まれたとすると
その人にとってはものすごい大胆な経験なんです
それはその人の文化 宗教観
背景によってその人解釈する
解釈してからその通りに生きていようとしちゃうんです
そうすると 一般の人々から見れば
この人は何者か 頭おかしいではないかと思うかもしれません
その人にも普通の世間に戻って行動することはできなくなっちゃう
それ 仏教の世界から見ればこういう風になります
例えば禅定作る時 土の色をとって瞑想する一つのシステムありますね
それはアビダンマ それから出ます
アビダンマという瞑想対象にする
土の色の対象を取って瞑想しちゃうと
どんどんイメージがというか
この何て言いますか 頭の中それ見えるようになって
どんどん全部そういう風に見られる